the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
good afternoon we are live
good afternoon and welcome to the ftth
council europe webinar series my name is
vincent garnier i'm the director general
of the ftth council europe and i will be
moderating this session
the ftth council europe is a trade
association regrouping 150 companies
covering the full spectrum
of the ftth value chain our mission is
to promote the development of full fiber
network
as the most sustainable future-proof
technology
which will enable a green and digital
europe this webinar
is one of the multiple actions we
undertake to share market and technology
information
to the large ftth and telecom ecosystem
so before i introduce the subject of
today
let me briefly mention the next two
webinar in our series
on june the 16th our members setix
key pro and packet front will present a
session title
breakdown network boundaries and on june
the
30th the council's investor committee
will release and introduce its guide to
successful
fiber business models watch out for
invitation and communication
regarding both events
just some housekeeping item about this
session
within a week you and all registrants to
this webinar
will receive an email with access to
the replay of the webinar and to the
slide deck which have been used today
now you can ask questions during this
session by
typing them in the dedicated box on the
platform
we will try and address them or most of
them time permitting
at the end of the session
and then without further due let's move
to the theme
of today historically the ftth council
has focused on bringing
fiber to the home today's this is not
enough
what truly matters for users is to bring
the full potential of fiber to the end
device
of the user with the increase of
bandwidth
brought by fiber we see more and more
gigabit services being offered
how can this quantity of data be
transmitted over wi-fi
from this perspective is wi-fi 6
a luxury or a necessity
and what needs to be done to manage
wi-fi 6
and properly benefit from its full
potential
these are some of the questions that our
speakers
will address in this session titled
separating the facts from the fiction
wi-fi seeks
demystified and with it's my great
pleasure to introduce you
to our speakers today bill mcfarland
cto at plum good afternoon bill
good morning very early morning for me
actually oh yeah that's right you you
you're calling from uh from the us
well thanks for for being with us at
such an early
uh hour for for your time zone and with
you is ronan kelly
uh cto at atran and good afternoon ronan
as far as you're concerned you're based
in ireland so this is definitely
afternoon
it's definitely easier for me and good
afternoon vincent and to everybody else
as well
so thanks really for for being with us
and and sharing
uh you your knowledge and expertise your
i don't know
demystifier in chief in your respective
organization
so i think we start with ronan uh and
running the floor is yours i think you
just need to move to presenter mode
and share your slide now perfect thank
you vincent appreciate the introduction
so good afternoon everybody hopefully
you can all see my slides
and first of all welcome to this the
latest in five of the home council
webinar series as vincent said today
we're going to focus on separating facts
from fiction
and focusing on demystifying wi-fi six
i'm sure many of you in the audience
already
know who i am due to my previous
presidency with the fiber of the home
council
europe but for those that i haven't had
the pleasure of meeting before
as vincent said i'm roman kelly and i'm
at trans chief technology officer
for the emea and apac regions for the
operators listening in on this call and
i know there are many of you listening
in today
you guys really need to pay attention to
what's going to get discussed today
because
there are a number of major movements
playing out in the industry
as we speak that are going to come
together collectively
and fundamentally they're going to break
your customers networks
quite possibly they're going to break
your call center
and there's a really strong potential
for many operators they may even break
your business model
so i think it's really important that
you pay attention to some of the
insights that we're going to share with
you guys today during the presentation
and atran we've been involved in access
network since the internet was a dial-up
experience and we watched the industry
grow
from the very original adsl you know
11 megabit per second type connections
and
right through the various different
variants of vdsl technologies and docsis
technologies
and now we're finally at the point where
fiber has become the de facto when it
comes to
broadband infrastructure and investment
which is a huge milestone for us to
achieve now and something i know the
council
has been pushing really really hard to
try and make sure that's happened and it
is now finally starting to happen
if we look i borrowed a slide here from
one of my colleagues eric joyce who's
the chair of the fiber of the home
council europe's market intelligence
committee
and on the slide we see a lot of data
that the council's partner ida
have helped compile that gives
visibility
with regard to the level of fiber
penetration that we're seeing across
europe
or more importantly the work that's been
done so far to date
which is represented in the pink bars
versus the work that remains to be done
in getting ubiquitous fiber coverage
across europe
and what we see very clearly is that
we've made some fantastic progress
over 50 percent of european households
now have access to a fiber to the home
connection
should they choose to available which is
a massive massive
important milestone however we also see
that there's quite a bit of work still
to be done
and particularly up towards the top of
the chart we see some of the main
population centers
still have a lot of work to do with
regard to getting ubiquitous fiber
coverage
however the fantastic news is that most
most of those countries
have already mobilized they already have
a very large number of operators
including
their traditional incumbent ptt
operators are now
investing heavily in fiber
infrastructure and
what we're seeing now is there's a huge
focus on
delivering against the targets that were
set down in the european electronic
communications code
which as a reminder was to deliver by
2025
and network connectivity into every
household that was capable of gigabit
connectivity
so we've got three and a half years yet
to play with
to get ubiquitous coverage for full
fiber across europe so it's a very short
period of time
from which we've got to change this
graph on the screen from being
predominantly blue
in the larger population centers to
being predominantly pink
now why is this important in the
discussion about wi-fi and particularly
wi-fi six well
we see the fiber foundations that are
being laid today as we speak in
every city every major population center
across europe
those foundations are going to serve as
the foundations that's going to
transition our societies from being
normal traditional connected societies
to becoming true
gigabit societies and this is going to
have very strong implications with
regard to
the availability of gigabit service
rates
and one of the things that we've seen
very clearly is as we get more and more
ubiquitous fiber
what follows very quickly is more and
more cost effective gigabit services and
we see that represented
on the screen now is just a sample
snapshot
of various different operators across
different countries in europe
where they're now really starting to
drive the democratization of gigabit
connectivity
we see in the top left hand side service
rates as low as 25 pound per month
for a symmetric gigabit experience and
all the way over you know some of the
loans on the higher end of things you
know still coming in underneath
100 pound per month the gigabit
experience is really starting to fall
into the realm of the elastic stand
that many households have for broadband
connectivity
and this is going to have implications
with regard to the the
end users as we start to bring those
larger and larger pipes into the home
the expectation is the users are going
to want to be able to utilize those
pipes
they're going to want to have that
gigabit connectivity to the primary
devices that they interact
with the rest of the world through and
when they don't have that experience
that's when we can expect
the call center volumes of complaints
and fault calls to increase and drive
the cost
of the operators this is further
compounded by
the number of devices that people are
connecting onto the network
this is a chart by a company called
audience project that they published a
report
that covered the growth in devices
connecting to the network in homes
across all the main population centers
around the world in the developed world
and they covered it from 2018 to 2020
and what we can see is there's roughly
around a 15 to 20 percent growth rate in
that period
now what i find quite interesting with
these numbers you know they're talking
an average number of devices in and
around nine and ten devices per
household
i think one of the things we have to
remember here is these are averages
and you know for those households like
your grandparents household that have
one device or maybe two devices
they're pulling down that overall
average i think in most households that
you know where you've got parents in
their kind of
mid-thirties late early forties etc
they've got a couple of kids in the mix
we typically expect to see in the range
of around 20 devices per household if
not higher
i know within my own home i'm
acknowledging i'm a lead user
like we've had more than 40 connected
devices in our household for
at least the last two or three years now
at this point and that's something that
continues to rise year on year
and we don't anticipate that slowing
down anytime in the near future
how the networks are getting used as
well is continuing to evolve
more and more towards a media
distribution network and we see now
we're at the point where
across all of the main streaming
platforms now there's over a
billion paid subscriptions across the
world collectively
with all of those streaming platforms so
users are expecting now as they avail of
services that you know they'll sign up
to a cloud-based delivered service
and they expect to be able to have
access to that service
in a high quality stable fashion
throughout their entire household it's
not a case that they want to be stood
right beside the access point in the
hall
just so that they can stream their
favorite 4k tv
content one thing a few things that
become very clear is
our networks must be robust and
ubiquitous throughout our home so that
the customers
you know if we if they can't enjoy their
tv experience they're going to get very
irate very quickly
and they're going to drive support calls
into the operators the networks are
going to get busier and busier as the
content to stream to more and more
connected devices
but also as the fidelity of that content
continues to increase
we're now very much in the 4k era and if
we look on the main streaming
channels from netflix or amazon etc
disney plus
4k content is proliferating with
all of the new titles that are being
released our dependency on the networks
is also increasing you know not only do
they secure our homes they also connect
us increasingly to our workplaces
as we've all found out over the last 18
months so that reliability becomes
increasingly important
we're now in that period where wi-fi
it's no longer a luxury i remember when
i first started interacting with wi-fi
it was in early 2000s
and you see on the bottom left hand
there's an old cisco
um pcmcia wi-fi adapter that i used to
have to borrow
in work from a pool of adapters that
were shared amongst the engineers
sure purely because of the expense of
the equipment
the industry continued to evolve and we
saw some early entrance into the
industry the likes of linksys and that
during the 802.11 g the 54 megabits per
second
era lynx has really secured strong
market adoption
but it was still very much the preserve
of lead users out there within the
marketplace
it was only as we went into the intel
centrino era
and with the emergence of um wi-fi
connected devices like the iphone
that we really started to see wi-fi get
democratized
across households around the world but
predominantly
as operators started to provide wi-fi as
a bundled piece with the
the broadband connectivity it was really
on a best effort basis it was kind of
they were doing the users a favor by
providing them with this wi-fi gateway
and if it wasn't working great you know
tough we're only responsible for the
broadband experience
but what we've seen now is we've moved
over towards wi-fi five
and streaming has become a ubiquitous
part of everybody's lives
consumers don't tolerate that anymore if
the operator
isn't willing to take control and help
them address their wi-fi challenges
then users will churn they'll move on to
the next operator
the way i describe it to operators when
i speak to them is you users don't buy
broadband they buy wi-fi
when things break they say the wi-fi is
not working they don't say the
broadband's not working
so now we're moving into the era of
wi-fi six and it's critically important
because as i mentioned error earlier
we're also moving into that era
of ultra high definition experiences
whether it's in video streaming or
gaming
or whether it's in video calling like
what we're doing now today
and in a work from home type environment
so we need something that can deliver
more than what wi-fi five was capable of
delivering
if we look at some of the main benefits
that wi-fi six brings to the table
first of all from a modulation
perspective we're getting much greater
density in the modulation schemes that
are applied so we've got a 102 for quant
modulation scheme
which is in a step up from the 256 cloud
that we had with wi-fi
five and realistically in usable
capacity it gives us about an extra 25
percent
reusable capacity we've also got the
ofdm
ofdma implementations as well and what
that allows us to do
is it allows us to subdivide the
spectrum that's available
between the users on the network but
more importantly we can subdivide even
further not just on frequency but on the
time domain as well
so that we can give slices of capacity
to users on the network
and that's really important as we move
into trying to implement quality of
service across the network
or to go further and use the the phrase
azure these days of network slicing
we have that capability in a wi-fi six
environment
there's a big focus on upstream as well
with multi-user mimo being applied in
the upstream direction
so that we can achieve much higher
capacities when we're doing activities
like what i'm doing with you now today
in video calling etc we've also got the
content
that the wi-fi industry trying to align
itself better with the iot space as well
so the concepts around
target wait time where devices that
particularly are operating on battery
power
they can avoid some of the the power
consuming activities of gaining access
to the network where they have to listen
out
to see if any users are on the network
instead they can pre-schedule
transmission time
with the access points so that when
they're ready to send at a set time a
day they just send
and the access point makes sure that the
channel is clear for them to do that
we're seeing that the broader use of 160
megahertz
channels as well and that's not new that
was available in wi-fi five but it
didn't really make its way into a lot of
end devices to take advantage of that
whereas we expect in the wi-fi six world
that that will become much more
ubiquitous out there
probably the biggest and most important
change though is with wi-fi 6e
and that's where effectively we're
doubling the available spectrum for use
in wi-fi
and so that as the original 5 gigahertz
spectrum starts to become
become congested in markets like the
united states
we've got a new 1.2 gigahertz worth of
spectrum available in the six gigahertz
shutdown
band so we can start to use that
initially between access points etc but
then as newer devices newer electronics
comes out whether it's laptops or
smartphones
that can avail of that six gigahertz and
spectrum they can also take advantage of
that additional capacity for a better
user experience
unfortunately in europe we've only got
500 megahertz of that spectrum available
at this point in time
hopefully that's something that will
approve into the future
as with all aspects of the telco
infrastructure these days we see a
strong push by the operator community
towards open
equipment implementations
we see from the operators that they're
sick and tired of being locked into
closed ecosystems
so now as they're moving towards this
new world where particularly they've got
multiple pieces of equipment inside the
home
where they're trying to deliver a meshed
experience to provide whole home
coverage
with a very high quality of experience
the challenge that they've got is if
they deploy a closed solution from a
single vendor
then they're tied into everything from
supply chain risk
through to the innovation capabilities
of that single vendor
so what we're seeing now is a strong
push by the operator community towards
an open implementation utilizing
approaches like opensync
where they can achieve the same whole
home coverage but they can use a
multitude of different vendors to
achieve that coverage
and they can mix and match between the
vendors so that way they can get
independence from
the chipsets that are applied in the
equipment they can get operating system
independence
they get choice in who they procure
their software for doing automatic
automation analytics telemetry even the
subscriber application tools because
there are open interfaces that can be
developed too
so as they move forward and start to
build out the infrastructure throughout
the homes based on these open
implementations
they can open up a whole new pool of
vendors that can feed into that open
ecosystem and bring around a whole new
range of innovations
that perhaps wouldn't be available in
such a timely fashion from the
traditional vendor community
the last point i'll touch on is the cost
of all of this equipment
there's no question that there is that
you know there's some very sophisticated
equipment coming out now in this new
wi-fi six era that can deliver an
exceptional consumer experience and
particularly
when augmented with cloud automation to
really optimize and maintain that
environment
but it's not cheap it costs quite a lot
of money and this is where
we're starting to see a lot of the
operators revert back to the very
original business model
that went with telecoms when the phone
lines were being built out
the cost of the original handsets was
prohibitive for many users and served as
a major barrier to adoption
and what the early phone companies did
was they provided that
handset as a service where basically you
would pay
an equipment rental as a component on
your bill every month
and we know how that worked out for many
of those operators they got to rent that
same piece of equipment for
20 plus years and you know it more than
paid for itself
and this is what we're now starting to
see across europe is there's a number of
innovative operators
both tier one and tier three and
everything in between
where they're starting to deliver a
superior wi-fi package as part of their
lineup
and they're renting the equipment to the
consumer as part of that
with a fixed term contract as well which
helps stem the rpu decline that they're
seeing
from the loss of services to over the
top so they're now
shoring back up those declines with new
revenue streams coming in from the
equipment rental
but also when it's their equipment
providing that gigabit experience
and that gigabit lifestyle throughout
the user's home it's much more difficult
for the user to just quickly flip over
to a different provider
because now they've got to reconsider
how their whole home is networked
and then also it opens up the
opportunity as i mentioned earlier
because of all the innovation that's
coming now with the open implementations
through opensync
it opens up the opportunity for new
revenue streams
for the service provider and bill who's
going to speak now in a couple of
seconds
we'll talk you through some of the
capabilities for opening up those new
revenue streams
when you build on top of that open sync
architecture
so with that i'd like to give it over to
bill mcfarland and bill is the cto for
adron's partner
via our open sync implementation with
plume networks
so bill over to you
and why bill is getting ready with this
slide that may i remind you that you can
still
ask questions type this question in the
in the question box we will address them
at the end
any question to run on or any question
around this topic will be addressed by
both bill and ronan
we can see your slide bill
okay do you see my slide correctly no
yes
absolutely thank you
i see that somehow skipped ahead a
little bit let me go back to the
beginning that's a good place to start
so i'm bill mcfarland um shown on this
slide here
are the main advantages of wi-fi six
ronin's already been through this a
little bit so i'll try to go quickly
most wi-fi 6 devices can use 160
megahertz frequency channels
those are twice as wide as earlier wi-fi
devices
and that allows them to go twice as fast
as previous generations of wi-fi
we have orthogonal frequency division
multiple access
currently you know commonly abbreviated
ofdma
which allows the delivery of small
packets simultaneously to a large number
of devices
and that improves the efficiency of
networks particularly for networks that
have a lot of
kind of smaller lightweight devices in
them you think about a home
that has a large number of wi-fi devices
in it typically a large number of those
are iot devices things like light bulbs
thermostats etc
those devices require a relatively
modest amount of traffic
but servicing them individually is very
inefficient so ofdma really helps with
that
network slicing reserves throughput in
the network for high priority real-time
traffic
and that improves the reliability of
audio and video in them
there's a feature called target wake
time or twt
this saves power by reserving the
airwaves for sleeping devices
these sleeping devices periodically wake
up to send and receive traffic
and if when they wake up the airwaves
are already clear they can very
efficiently send and receive their
traffic and go back to sleep
rather than having to stay awake longer
waiting for other devices to get out of
the way so that ability to reserve
time on the airwaves really helps with
battery life actually
and then there's wi-fi 6e that ee stands
for extended
it makes use of the new six gigahertz
spectrum
which is allocated in the us and other
geographies providing more spectrum
to avoid interference and use wide
channel bandwidths
but it does complicate things as we'll
talk about
later now all of these features
kind of work well out of the box in an
ideal environment if you have just one
access point
and no interference if you're
effectively in a wi-fi vacuum
uh then these features work great just
as it comes on the ap
by itself but in practice few
environments are really
a wi-fi vacuum more
realistic environments that wi-fi works
in have three different scenarios of
interference between
access points there can be interference
from one neighboring wi-fi system
to your home wi-fi system right so you
can have
these neighboring wi-fi systems that
might not be centrally managed
each ap is making independent choices
about how to operate
and this represents kind of foreign
interference that comes into your home
potentially from your neighbors
there are also environments such as
apartment complexes that have multiple
aps that interfere with each other but
the unique thing about these
environments is that all of these ips
these aps might all be part of the same
centrally managed system
for example a service provider might
have a contract with an apartment
complex
and it might make use of essentially
managed systems such as plumes
to manage all the aps from the cloud
this represents kind of like in system
interference and it opens
the possibility of doing some other
things in order to make the situation
better in that case
finally as ronan pointed out there's a
move towards having multiple access
points in a single home
to ensure full coverage of the home i
did erase throughout the home
and so forth and so here
in this scenario you actually have
self-interference your own traffic as it
goes through multiple hops through the
network
becomes your own congestion in your own
home
and of course a given home can be
experienced potentially all three
of these types of interference
simultaneously this foreign interference
in system interference and
self-congestion
to make wi-fi fix and 6e work well in
these types of real
environments it turns out you really
need centralized intelligent
management it's kind of counterintuitive
but wi-fi six
requires actually more management than
previous generations of wi-fi not
less the management required can be
broken into four categories and i'll go
through them
for you to understand better what types
of management what this management is
that's actually required
the four categories are band management
channel management
steering management and time management
so to demonstrate the complicated band
management requirements that wi-fi 6
brings into play
we're going to take a look at a
particular example assume you have a
network with aps that have three radios
so it's effectively a tri-band ap
in which two of the radios have a two by
two mimo capability those are radios
that can go about
twice normal speed we'll call it
baseline speed
and one of the radius has a four by four
mimo capability and that allows it to go
at a
at a four times baseline speed
a common hardware arrangement would be
to have one two by two radio and a 2.4
gigahertz band to serve legacy clients
for example
in this diagram it's labeled as channel
six the other two by two radio in the
lower half of the five gears band this
might be on a frequency channel called
channel 42 for example
and the third four by four radio tunable
between the upper half
of the five gears band or it can be
moved into the six gigahertz band in
this
diagram they're labeled channel 155
lower half of the five gears band
and what i label is channel 615 in the
six gigahertz span
now uh the first network tech model
topology that i show the network is
arranged much as it would be if
it were a wi-fi five network the
backhaul is in the five gigahertz band
using the 4x4 radio the highest
performance radio
and in some systems such as plumes that
radio can also be used for wi-fi clients
to attach
to this is quite valuable actually
because it allows devices with a strong
wi-fi capability such as a macbook with
its 3x3 mimo radio
to connect at full speed now you might
think this topology can be improved by
putting that backhaul connection in the
six gigahertz band
and on the right hand side of the slide
we're showing an example of that
however while using the six gigahertz
panel for the backhaul might improve the
backhauling
it would avoid interference and allow
clean use of a
160 megahertz wide channel on the
backhaul
if the macbooks don't have six gigahertz
capability
and they don't today obviously the
quality of the connection to the client
is
actually degraded so the question
becomes
which of these topologies is better the
one with the
macbook connected to the four by four
radio and the five gigahertz fan
or the one with the six gigahertz
backbone but the macbook's connected on
a two by two connection to a less
powerful five gigahertz radio
it turns out that you know as i like to
say i'm not smart enough to answer that
question
uh to get benefit rather than
degradation from wi-fi 6e
what plume does is it uses machine
learning artificial intelligence
effectively implemented in the cloud
to understand the pattern of device
usage
interference and services coming from
individual homes
to proactively optimize the network for
the traffic that will be present
essentially you have to learn does the
network need a lot of backlog capability
does the network have a lot of these
high
capacity clients in it do these high
capability clients
want to move a lot of traffic frequently
all of those factor into the decision
about which of these topologies is
actually better
and which is worse and so again when you
think about
wi-fi six coming this availability of
the six gigahertz band
it becomes more complicated not less
complicated to decide how to correctly
configure your networks
now along with choosing which band each
radio should operate in
intelligent selection the frequency
channel for each radio also benefits
wi-fi networks
this challenge has been present in
previous generations but wi-fi 6 brings
two additional
complications to thinking about channel
allocation
first wi-fi 6 devices generally include
the ability to operate at 160 megahertz
wide channels
so this is nice because it can double
the speed and in many geographies
you know but the disadvantage is that in
many geographies like
the united states europe there are only
260 megahertz channels available
and so that networks that use 160
megahertz channels can be very
vulnerable to interference if you're in
an apartment complex
everyone's trying to use 160 megahertz
channels there's only two different
frequencies to choose from
obviously you're going to have a lot of
channel sharing you're going to have a
lot of interference
now the question becomes when should 160
megahertz be used
which homes really deserve it using 160
megahertz also throws interference into
neighboring homes
so the question is who and how much is
it damaging the experience of
other users in your own system so again
we have a complicated set of decisions
to make regarding that when we look at
another complication that wi-fi six
brings which is this
technology called bss color that's a
tool
that wi-fi six brings to help with
interference from overlapping networks
the diagram here shows a theoretical
arrangement of four homes
on four different frequency channels in
this case they're just
labeled one two three four and a variety
of colors
the colors is a notion in wi-fi six that
allows an ap to transmit
even when a signal is present on the
same channel
if it's coming from a different color
generally speaking the way wi-fi works
is it's
what we call listen before talk if there
is
any other wi-fi system in the whole area
transmitting
on the same frequency channel as you're
operating on then you defer to it you
don't transmit
until that other transmitter has
finished their transmission
but in this case what we're going to do
is we're going to intentionally kind of
step on that other transmission i
liken it to having a conversation in a
crowded room if there's someone right
next to you talking very loud then you
don't try to talk over them
but if there's someone talking at the
far end of the room
at a relatively soft level where you are
you might go ahead and speak
to someone who's standing close to you
so the idea is the same
here the colors allow an ap to transmit
even when a signal is present on the
same channel if it's coming from a
different color
and as long as the transmission is is
from a different network
which is sufficiently far away both
networks can transmit at the same time
without interfering with each other
so as you can imagine from the example i
gave about talking at a party
this can either be effective or it can
just create additional chaos
and collisions
the system needs to make a number of
correct decisions again to make this
work
which ap gets which channel which color
and what received signal strength should
you go ahead and transmit on top of
another transmission
so wi-fi brings these 160 megahertz
channels it brings bss color both of
which require
rigorous intelligent optimization to
ensure
consumers benefit from these advances
rather than suffering from
ofdma is you know kind of the marquee
feature for wi-fi six
it's the thing that people talk about a
lot it's what promises this
tremendous growth in the number of wi-fi
iot devices without overly congesting
networks
and that's important because we see
devices going up very
quickly ronin was current talking about
some of the statistics they see
we did a study on our network and today
10 of our users have 40
or more wi-fi devices in their homes
and 20 have more than 30
three devices in their home and what we
saw also was that that number grew by
25 percent across the last
year if you project that out by 2025
10 of homes might have as many as a
hundred wi-fi devices
in them now i'm not guaranteeing that
that kind of growth rate will
continue last year was a somewhat
unusual year with kovit and everything
but it does indicate that the number of
wi-fi devices in people's homes is
growing very rapidly
and could become a real issue for wi-fi
networks
now the way ofdma works is that it
allows an access point to put together a
single transmission which contains a
small amount of information for each of
many receivers
by combining what would have been many
transmissions into a single packet
a large amount of wasted air time is
saved however
more and more homes are getting multiple
access points to ensure good coverage
and high data rates throughout the home
it turns out this presence of multiple
aps can make it difficult
for ofdma to do its job now here there's
an example from here imagine a home with
eight
iot devices in this example and four
access points
if the iot devices are kind of
distributed among all the aps in the
home
there might be only two devices per ap
so what this means is that each ap can
only aggregate two devices
into their ofdma transmissions that
really limits the amount of benefit that
you might be able to get from ofdma
a potential fix would be to have only
one
ap do this ofdma function
and move all of the iot clients to that
access point
the problem with this approach you can
kind of intuit from the way this is
drawn
is that some devices might be too far
from the access point requiring
transmission at a very low data rate
again destroying any potential
efficiency gain you know when devices
get out to the edge of range in a wi-fi
system they start transmitting at a low
data rate they take a lot of air time
the whole system becomes inefficient
once again so
for each home you know kind of like as i
i like it at the store of goldilocks and
the three bears
for each home there is a kind of just
right solution
that balances this aggregation desire
to get a lot of devices on single access
points so fdma can be effective
with the ability to connect to nearby
access points where your signal strength
is the strongest and where you can go at
the highest data rate
so the correct topology for each home
will be different depending on the
clients the traffic patterns
the layout of the home and the access
points in the home
and so again what's really required is
an intelligent system that optimizes the
network
and sets it up individually and in a
different way for each individual home
so wi-fi six brings two features that
try to manage air time
for advantage target wake time again
this saves power by reserving time slots
for sleeking devices to wake and
communicate
and network slicing to reserve time and
frequency slots for high priority data
flows
as with other features making these work
effectively in a multi-ap environment is
especially tricky so there's a diagram
here that shows
a home that might have three access
points in it and a bunch of clients
the clients distributed among the access
points in the home
looking at this if we think about how
this twt
or target wake time reservation of time
slots might go
ap-1 might reserve a twt sine slot
for phone p1 for example in this diagram
however ap2 in home might reserve an
overlapping
twt slot for p2 so now what happens is
the two awakening phones
which might in practice be fairly close
to each other in the home
they wake up and they'll interfere with
each other during their twt slots
either they transmit at the same time
and collide or they have to wait for
each other to get done
that defeats the entire purpose of
having the twt
protocol the right thing to do is kind
of complicate it for p1 it's important
that apu2
reserve that twt slot even though none
of its clients will use it so
on ap2 it's like hey i'm going to
reserve this slot but i'm going to
reserve it for none of my clients
to allow the right things to happen in
ap1 on the other hand
ap3 might be far enough away that does
not need to reserve that slot
finally the twt slots at ap2 probably
have to be reserved at both 81 and 83.
the possible scenarios for this as you
can imagine are nearly infinite and
depend
again specifically on what's going on in
each individual particular home
now similarly network slicing where we
reserve slots for high
priority traffic needs to be coordinated
across multiple aps as well
and network slicing has the added
complication that some high priority
traffic must
traverse multiple hop so it's got to go
all the way across the network from end
to end
and that involves pops in the backbone
uh or the backhaul of the network as
well as hops out to the individual
client
and timeout needs to be allocated for
the high priority traffic flow
has to be reserved on each hop
considering whether that hop is on the
same frequency channel
as another hop in the home or whether
it's on a different frequency channel
the scenarios shown here are for a
multi-ap home but similar scenarios can
exist in single ap homes that have
interference from neighbors
or interference from other units within
an mdu
and so coordination across multiple aps
both in homes and even between homes
is again particularly beneficial for
wi-fi six if you really want to get
benefit out of these
new technologies in wi-fi six and the
improvements that come from them
you really have to be doing this
sophisticated kinds of optimization
so wi-fi six is a big improvement you
know as much as we're talking about
the complications of it and the
difficulties of using all these new
features
it is a big improvement and service
providers should be excited about
deploying it
the question becomes you know how do you
get the technology particularly in a way
that enables
centralized management that it really
needs
it turns out there is a convenient way
and ronan talked about this as well
opensync is an open sourced software
agent
that can be put on an access point and
it enables that ap
to be monitored and controlled by the
cloud
opensync includes a software-defined
networking capability
which allows it not only to manage wi-fi
but to implement other services as well
services such as cyber security parental
controls
and even wi-fi motion detection again
ronan was talking about
some of the ways that service providers
can make up for
lost arpu as certain services are kind
of drifting away
such as video services
and he mentioned you know being able to
rent new types of equipment and more
sophisticated
systems like wi-fi it's also possible to
bring
new services into the home that
consumers are very willing to pay for
that are different services and maybe
had been previously supplied by service
providers such as cyber security
parental controls
motion detection can be used to create a
physical alarm system it can alert me
if i'm out of the house when there's
motion happening
it also can be used as a wellness
monitoring system i might have elderly
parents that i want to know
got up in the morning and made it to the
kitchen and had breakfast
now this open sink uh turns out that it
has grown
tremendously in popularity it's
supported by all the major chipset
manufacturers
it comes pre-integrated in aps from a
wide variety of vendors and tran is one
of those
and it has been adopted by leading
service providers
both large and small and you know now it
supports wi-fi
six one thing that's nice about open
sync is that if you
put it into your system it runs equally
well on wi-fi five even
going back to what was uh nominally
wi-fi four
um and wi-fi 6 and you could have even
had mixed environments
where you have some wi-fi 6 devices and
some wi-fi
5 devices and it operates very well on
those devices as well
with the current silicon shortage there
can be supply
issues and if you're trying to roll out
wi-fi six to all your customers
can be the case that that becomes a
little bit challenging to do in the
immediate future
that's another advantage of opensync is
that you can deploy
opensync this software technology and
still allow you to make a lot of forward
progress
even while you are still having wi-fi
five
or previous generations available in a
lot of your homes
as you're rolling out wi-fi six
throughout your network
thank you so i do think that wi-fi six
is a great exciting opportunity
and i think that everyone should be
looking forward to that and making plans
to deploy that
but you have to tend to other aspects of
your network as well and make sure you
have a good wi-fi management system in
place
that can benefit all of your wi-fi
systems thank you
thank you bill uh and thank you ronan we
now move to
and i'm gonna
share my screen in a second but
while i'm i'm doing this we already have
some question
coming in and i will immediately move to
the
to the first one um
interesting one um if you were to
it comes from i think uh rebecca and
she's asking us
if you had to pick one what is the
biggest challenge customer
are expecting wi-fi six to solve
i guess i think you address this one
i was on a panel at one time where they
actually had a survey
question about that and the highest
response was actually
interference congestion problems um
and so i thought that was interesting
and then the second was uh the handling
of a large number of devices in the home
and i think that those answers are are
pretty perceptive in a way
you know usually when a new wi-fi
technology rolls out there's a lot of
focus on the higher data rates and so
forth and that part of wi-fi six i think
is important but i do think that it's
more that interference
and handling lots of clients which is
you know the unique
aspect of wi-fi six i think also as well
there's probably a lot of the basics
that are not well implemented in a lot
of the existing wi-fi for
wi-fi five solutions that are out there
today that people will kind of
anticipate wi-fi five is
or sorry wi-fi six is going to fix
simple things like hand over between aps
in a multi-ap home when not done
properly can result in a really
frustrating and very poor experiences
people get stickiness as they move
around their home etc and
i think a lot of them kind of look
towards wi-fi six as being the solution
towards that when in reality
is not necessarily wi-fi standard
implementation it's going to help with
that it's more a better implementation
in the software on the access points
they're using
thank you i have another question from
neil regarding
the effective throughput we can expect
to have from wi-fi six he is mentioning
that in traditional wi-fi connection
according to him
uh the effective throughput is
approximately two-thirds of the
of the connection speed and he's
wondering whether wi-fi 6 changes that
pattern
i think it i don't speak for bill but i
think it's going to depend on the
architectural implementation of the
device that you're using as well
that is a large part to do with the
overall performance that you can achieve
versus the bandwidth that's available
via the wi-fi connection
there's so some of the other things that
i've seen like even simple things like
you know the we noticed at one point
with my son's xbox
when he was complaining saying dad the
wi-fi is not working and i took a look
at it and sure enough he was trying to
download a game
and it was only coming down at 20
megabits per second but he had his wi-fi
connection i
checked it on the plume up and he could
see the things connected at 250 mega
seconds
via wi-fi and i'm scratching my head
because the broadband is one gig fiber
connection thankfully these days
and i'm saying what's going wrong here
and after a little bit of investigation
i just through troubleshooting with him
i said are you playing a game at the
moment he says yeah it's such and such
on the background
and he says can you kill that game and
just see what happens so he kills the
game
and sure enough all of a sudden the
download starts ramping up
100 meg 150 meg 200 meg and i said okay
start the game again just to see what
happens
and he starts the game again and sure
enough it falls back down to 20 megs
through push
now one of the things i've noticed now
with the very latest xbox series x is
they actually
highlight that on the screen for you
they say if you leave these games open
this is going to take longer to download
so so some of the
the uh producers or manufacturers of the
products are
becoming aware that their product has a
direct impact on the consumer experience
over the wi-fi infrastructure
and thankfully they're taking a bit of
ownership around that as well
yeah and i just add that you know wi-fi
6 does have
some different modes of operation
but on the whole you know wi-fi as an
industry has this tradition of quoting
speeds by what we call
the physical layer data rate and that
does not
factor for all the overhead associated
with some of the protocols that have to
be running and
protocols associated with uh ip
protocols themselves
and so i think that the the basic notion
you have that is about two-thirds
of the quoted physical layer data rate
will be pretty consistent for wi-fi six
as well
okay i have a question from france and
and he's wondering
um if wi-fi six
he mentioned six gigahertz atelier
and and frequency uh how did his
attenuation
uh compared to to what uh happens with
uh the different flavor of of previous
wi-fi especially when it comes to you
know going through
concrete wall and and brick wall uh
bill unlike the us uh here in europe we
have very thick walls
and uh we suffer from
that constraint when it comes to uh
wireless frequency
propagation and attenuation so is there
anything different
for wi-fi six uh from that perspective
yeah so you know here in the us we build
our houses out of what could
pretty well be described as paper but
it's true that in other environments
the houses can be built out of much
sturdier materials
and it is an issue uh you know six
gigahertz the higher the frequency the
worse the propagation
the difference between six gigahertz and
five gigahertz is probably not going to
be huge
because there is a uh you know
on a percentage basis it's not that
different we see noticeable difference
between 2.4 and 5 gigahertz and one of
the things that plume has is
in its system is um very uh
sophisticated what we call down steering
because you can have an event
where as someone's moving further and
further away from the access point
the best thing to do is to actually have
them shift down from being connected on
the five gigahertz band
to have them being connected on a 2.4
gigahertz span and we will actually kind
of forcibly
make that client downshift into the 2.4
gigahertz band so it can actually be
connected better
as it moves farther away now the six
gigahertz span has another complication
to it which is that under some
circumstances the allowed transmit power
is less than in the five gigahertz band
and that's a complicated topic i didn't
go into but it has to do with whether
you have
what's called an afc system that looks
for other competing
types of services in the area that are
the primary users of that six gigahertz
span
and that determines whether you can use
the higher level power or the lower
level power
but on the whole yes it will be the case
that six gigahertz
is even a little bit more challenged for
propagating throughout homes
and again it's another reason why i
think you need to make very intelligent
decisions factoring where are the
clients
where are additional access points in
the home how strong are the links in the
back hall between access points and so
forth
whether to use the six gigahertz scan or
not to use it because
it is possible despite it being kind of
this new spectrum and clean
and interference free and so forth uh it
is possible to make the network
run worse using the six gigahertz
spectrum than it would with just the
five gigahertz spectrum
i think also as well vincent some of the
things that we have to take into account
for are things like the new building
regulations as well so increasingly we
see
for example the foil back building
materials that are used in new
homes for uh thermal regulations etc
and they wreak havoc with any of the
wi-fi systems and six gigahertz is not
exempt from that
and i think to that extent it's still
critically important even though you
know
we're very much of a wireless mindset
throughout the home
it's critically important that the the
the aps the gateways themselves
and the extender aps throughout the home
at least have that facility available
that they can take a wired ethernet
connection
for households where it's just simply
not practical to get or have to
propagate through the materials that are
involved
okay thank you very much um
an interesting question at least from my
perspective from thomas
um what about power consumption of wi-fi
6
compared to legacy wi-fi and may i maybe
extend the question
what about the wi-fi 6
including its management carbon
footprint compared to
preview generations
bill do you want to go first or july why
don't you start
sure um i think one of the things that
really drives power consumption across
the wi-fi network
is congestion whenever we get a
congested environment where we get an
awful lot of re-transmission
basically the effort to achieve the same
outcome is significantly greater
so having the extra spectrum that
available to us that wi-fi six can
deliver
and also the extra capacity that can be
achieved on the wi-fi six networks means
transmission times are significantly
less
which helps drive down the power
consumption i think when it gets into
the cloud-managed environment
there is the ability to power down
things that are not actively in use as
well so there are opportunities for
further power savings there as well now
obviously you've got to offset that
against the cost of the compute cycles
operating within the cloud
but when you spread that over you know
tens if not hundreds of thousands of
customers
i think that that additional cost adder
from not even a call standard but power
consumption
per user is negligible
yeah and i think i would add the comment
that you know although wi-fi six is a
more
sophisticated technology requires more
processing and so forth
uh uh we are getting the benefit of
course of
semiconductor technology almost evolving
and becoming low power inherently by
itself
so when we look at the wi-fi six
solutions i would say on the whole it's
kind of similar power levels from our
observation
uh as it was for wi-fi five a more
sophisticated technology using a more
advanced uh semiconductor
technology kind of comes out equal
okay i see uh
several questions and i'll take the one
coming from
from daria and it's talking about how do
we manage a mix
of uh devices some of them being
based on other wi-fi uh model and and
with the arrival of wi-fi 6
in homes how do you do manage this
hybrid situation
uh between the different generation of
wi-fi six
so i can comment oh ronan you go ahead
no go ahead go please oh okay um so
um first off uh luckily the wi-fi
alliance has a very strong
you know uh determination to make sure
that all
uh new generations of wi-fi are fully
compatible with the older generations of
wi-fi
so you know generally speaking if you
put a wi-fi 6 access point in a home
it will be able to communicate very well
with wi-fi 5
devices now what gets trickier
is this new band so for example the six
gigahertz band
obviously previous generation devices
could not operate in the six gigahertz
frequency band
and if you put an access point in the
home that uses the six gigahertz band
none of those legacy devices are ever
going to go up into that frequency band
and this is where we get into this
complicated question about am i kind of
wasting my resources up in six gigahertz
or is that actually beneficial to me
particularly
in the early days when there aren't so
many uh six gigahertz capable clients
um but the other thing is that certain
of the
new technologies and capabilities like
ofdma
they similarly only work with wi-fi six
devices a legacy wi-fi five device
cannot participate
in that ofdma style of transmission
and so to the extent that a customer
already has a large number of light
bulbs or something in their house that
are wi-fi five light bulbs
those are not going to get the
efficiency improvement
coming from wi-fi six by putting a wi-fi
six ap in that home
but as uh consumers build a larger
collection of wi-fi six devices in the
home they do get that advantage of ofdma
so it all does interoperate but not all
of the features and benefits are accrued
uh to the legacy devices
uh to be honest bill covered everything
i was going to cover so
so maybe maybe you can address this one
i mean you mentioned in your
introduction
um the fact that operators business
model could be impacted by all the
evolution we're currently seeing
so looking at wi-fi seeks revolution
from the angle
of business model and how to market
services do you think that
wi-fi six opens new opportunity and
require
a change in the business model of
operator to
to leverage uh the yeah the services
enabled by wi-fi six basically
um whatever question but over and above
new services that we can bring to market
and sell particularly higher speed tiers
etc and sell reliably
i think one of the biggest challenges
that operators are facing into now
when i speak with some of the larger
operators across europe
increasingly i've heard the figure rise
over the last couple of years where
you know three four years ago they used
to talk about you know they were very
nervous you know forty percent of the
support holes that they were dealing
with
were being resolved due to interaction
with the wi-fi environment
that moved on to 50 and then onwards up
to 65
as the years continue to progress is
that the one capacity continued to rise
in excess of what
people could achieve across the land
hence the support calls continue to rise
accordingly with it so
for the operators to really get control
of that in-home wire
wi-fi environment whether it's wi-fi
five or wi-fi six
is i don't wanna say it's irrelevant
because it's not it's very relevant
but they can achieve far far greater
gains by just taking control of the
environment
and introducing automation into
optimizing that environment as well
the way i've described it in other talks
that i've given to the industry
this managing a wi-fi environment is
like playing whack-a-mole
you know you can do a truck roll and
send an engineer out and they'll
optimize a customer's house and it'll
all be fantastic
for a couple hours and then the
neighbors come home and start to switch
stuff on and the microwave is turned on
and
so on and so forth and we get all sorts
of interference sources
that weren't there when the optimization
occurred and
what do you do you roll do another truck
roll and send another engineer out to
re-optimize things etc
you have to introduce automation to this
problem throwing humans at this problem
it's just simply not scalable and this
is where
for an awful lot of the service
providers they're factoring in oh
we're building a full fiber network so
our maintenance costs are going to be a
fraction of what the copper guys
maintenance costs are
because the fiber never breaks and
they're absolutely right but the problem
they're going to have is
it's not the fiber that's going to be
the big problem they're facing into it's
going to be that in-home wi-fi
environment
as those speed tiers over the fiber
become more and more ubiquitous open
around the gigabit range
that's where people are going to
struggle to achieve what they're paying
for and when they feel they're not
getting what they're paying for they're
either going to churn
or they're going to ring the support
desks we're getting to to the end of the
session ron and
bill maybe on this subject or on any
other issue do you want to have a few
words of conclusion because we
shortly need to wrap up yeah i just echo
exactly what ronan said it almost looks
like uh
you know like a layered system when you
think about monetization of wi-fi six
you know the bottom layer the basic
thing is you have reduced support calls
reboot reduce truck rolls which saves
money significant money
you know above that you have a basic
notion of
customer satisfaction and that strongly
relates to churn
you know rolling out uh new gear like
wi-fi six pleasing your customers with
exceptional wi-fi
performance and capabilities and a more
stable network
churn is super expensive right it's even
more expensive than truck rolls
uh and calls and and then at the top
here
are new services and wi-fi six does
enable some of these new services
a centralized management system uh you
know which has these additional features
can enable it as well when we think
about cyber security we think about
parental controls
again those can be applied either to try
to increase our boo they can be a
premium
service that you actually sell or they
can be just a you know customer
satisfaction
element to prevent churn so there's
quite a
few different ways to look at the
monetization of it but i think we
definitely feel like
this new technology makes customers very
happy
and customers being happy is always
worth money
well thank you bill thank you to our
audience
very engaged audience we could just take
a fraction of the question you
you sent to us as i said earlier replay
presentation deck will be sent to all
participants
so i just want to thank ronand and bill
for for their insights
um and i hope to to see you again on one
of our webinar
stay tuned you will receive invitation
for for the next sessions of
ftth council webinar series thank you
again
and have a good rest of your day thank
you
thank you